indonesia is facing its biggest surge of
coronavirus infections
so far the delta variant has rapidly
pushed up case numbers in indonesia
leaving hospitals in a critical state
and facing a shortage of oxygen to treat
patients
the government now says it's preparing
for a worst-case scenario
camped outside an overcrowded hospital
covered 19 patients
fighting for their lives the highly
contagious delta variant has swept
through
indonesia overwhelming the health system
and leaving families in a desperate hunt
for oxygen
for stricken relatives
i used to refill at a kiosk near home
but there's no supply there so i came
here
the government is struggling to fill the
gap
the demand for oxygen has increased
three to four-fold
and that's hampered distribution
there is indeed a shortage and we have
asked the five
biggest oxygen suppliers to dedicate 100
of their production to medical needs
to stop the spread of the coronavirus
the government has imposed a partial
lockdown
it also wants to step up vaccination
efforts
but with doses in short supply and only
around five percent of the population
fully vaccinated
another shortage is making itself felt
to cope with the rising death toll
farmland across the country
is hastily being converted into
makeshift graveyards
well the charity group say the children
says it's deeply worried about the
impact of the pandemic on children in
indonesia
i'm joined now by dino satria from save
the children in indonesia mr satya
thanks for your time
children have been globally generally
less affected by
covert 19 than adults but the number of
indonesian children contracting the
coronavirus has tripled since
may and more and more are dying why is
that
yes um good morning to you too um well
we
really don't know uh why this is
happening uh
but of course the the the statistics
says that around 12.5
um cases of cockpit is children this is
what
gives us very concerning and
um and the reason is one of the reasons
perhaps
and one of the things that we are trying
to advocate government
is to distribution of vaccine especially
to children
which the government already done the
past couple of days
but indonesia is very large areas
and and basic services is already
difficult
um depending where you live basically
and
uh where we work in remote areas
basic searches such as health facilities
is also difficult
and um and especially also to get the
vaccines is also
very difficult as well so this buddha
vaccine is not
widely uh distributed uh widely enough
and i think this is one of the cause of
the spread especially for children as
well how will
indonesia cope and countries like it
with the with vaccines
remaining in such short supply and as
you say those access issues
how will they manage to combat the
coronavirus
yes i think um of course the government
is doing
whatever they can right now uh but i
think
indonesia also uh needs to reach out to
different
um government or other
countries to support this vaccine and
also
uh trying to speed up this process
um looking at internal resources as well
such as
industries corporates that can help to
you know deliver these vaccine more
um spreadingly all over indonesia
basically i mean um
indonesia is also has a lot of resources
as well
basically it's just how to manage that
and um
uh to dissipate it uh widely enough and
what other measures
are the indonesian government taking to
try and combat this surge
yes now the government already have a
stricter restriction
since uh two or three days ago but
personally i hope that was happening
um like two or three weeks ago uh
but of course that's only focusing on in
japan island
uh but we are also addressing the
government that
will have more widely social restriction
across indonesia as well
of course this will be a lot of
challenges uh definitely especially for
the economic side
uh for uh community as well
indeed all right dino thank you very
much dino satria from save the children
in
indonesia let's take a look now at some
other developments in the pandemic
data from israel shows the biontech fisa
vaccine is
less effective at preventing mild
coronavirus infections
scientists believe this is because of
the highly transmissible delta variant
but they say the vaccine is still highly
effective in stopping
serious illness or hospitalizations
germany has announced it will ease
quarantine rules for travellers from the
uk
portugal russia india and nepal those
who are fully vaccinated will no longer
need to isolate after they enter the
country
and luxembourg's prime minister is in a
serious but stable condition in hospital
after contracting covert 19.
savier bettel was partially vaccinated
against the virus after one astrazeneca
jab